hi everyone
this is professor m.science and today i
want to compare pure and mixed states in
another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics
we know that probability plays a key
role in quantum mechanics because we can
only make probabilistic predictions
about measurement outcomes but
probability also plays a wider role in
science when we only have
partial information about our system for
example when we have a macroscopic
system and we have to use
statistical mechanics to describe it
what i want to do today is to compare
these two types of probability and
hopefully convince you that how
probability features in quantum
mechanics
is fundamentally different to how it
features when we only have partial
information about the system to make
things even more exciting there are
problems in which both types of
probability
are important and what we'll see today
is how pure and mixed quantum states are
all we need to describe both
let's go let's start with a simple
example
imagine that we have an observable a
associated with some physical property
and that this is its eigenvalue equation
where lambda n are the eigenvalues
and u n the eigenstates in our example
we're only going to consider two
eigenstates
say u1 and u2 we assume they correspond
to distinct eigenvalues so we can
straightaway say that they are
orthogonal
we're also going to assume that they're
both normalized
now imagine that we built a quantum
state psi as a linear superposition of
these two
states where we insist that the
coefficients c1 and c2 obey this
relation
to ensure that psi is normalized
we're now going to consider what happens
when we measure property a
in state psi we know from the videos on
measurements
that the only possible outcome of a
measurement of a is one of the
eigenvalues lambda
in this particular example one option is
to get eigenvalue lambda 1
and we'll get it with probability p
lambda 1 given by this expression
which we can also rewrite like this and
we also know from postulate 5 of quantum
mechanics about state collapse
that right after the measurement the
state of the system changes from
psi to u1 the other option
is to get eigenvalue lambda 2 and we'll
get it with this probability
also given by this and in this case
right after the measurement the state
changes from psi
to u2
the state we were just discussing is
called the superposition state
what i want to do now is to go over the
measuring framework again
but we'll organize it in a specific way
that will allow us to compare it with a
different framework in a moment
the first step in the framework is to
set up the system
in our superposition state the system is
simply made of one state
psi which is a superposition of u1
and u2 the second step is to select a
state
we only have one state psi so we have no
choice our state is psi
this step is completely deterministic
the third and final step is to perform a
measurement of a
we know from postulate four of quantum
mechanics that we can have two possible
outcomes we can get lambda 1 with this
probability
or we can get lambda 2 with this
probability
as we know very well by now the
measurement step is probabilistic
what i want to do next is to create a
new framework that will actually to the
same measurement results but we'll get
there in a completely different way
this new framework is called a
statistical mixture of states
the first step is again to set up the
system our system is now made of many
copies of
state u1 and many copies of state u2
to be precise we have n1 copies of state
u1
and n2 copies of state u2 this number of
copies is such
that the fraction of copies of state u1
which is n1 over n1 plus n2
is given by the absolute value of c1
squared
and the fraction of copies of state u2
is given by the absolute value of c2
squared
the second step is to select the state
what we now do
is to pick one state at random from this
collection of states and we may get u1
with this probability or we may get u2
with this probability so in a
statistical mixture of states
the second step which is selecting our
state is probabilistic
finally we can now go to the measurement
step in this case as both u1 and u2
are eigenstate of the operator a we're
measuring then we know with certainty
what the result of the measurement will
be
if we have state u1 then the result will
be lambda 1
and if we have state u2 then the result
will be lambda2
this step is therefore deterministic
now that we have these two frameworks
let's compare them
both frameworks have a probabilistic
step but in the first it is here
and the rise is at the measurement step
from the postulate of quantum mechanics
whereas in the second framework it is
here and it simply reflects the fact
that we only have
partial information about our system
something that has nothing to do with
quantum mechanics and that can also
happen in classical mechanics
so these two frameworks are
fundamentally different
however the surprising thing is that
from the point of view of performing a
measurement the two situations are
actually completely equivalent they give
the same answer
all we can predict in both cases is the
probability of a given outcome
and the probabilities that we predict in
both cases are the same
for lambda 1 it is given by this and for
lambda 2 it is given by this
so what's really going on i mean this
seems to suggest that we could obtain
the correct result of a measurement
not by following what we've claimed are
the rules of quantum mechanics
in the first framework but instead by
having a framework in which measurements
are deterministic
and all that happens is that we don't
have enough information about the system
such that we don't know which of the two
possible states here
u1 or u2 will pick
in the rest of the video i want to
further explore these two frameworks
and we'll actually learn that we need to
become familiar with both
because although they apply to different
situations they're both very useful
so with this the first thing i want to
do is to convince you that there is no
way
to avoid probabilistic measurements in
quantum mechanics
the correct way to calculate measurement
outcomes in quantum mechanics does
require
superposition states
to do this we need to consider our
original observable a
with the dissociated eigenvalue equation
and the second observable b
with its own associated eigenvalue
equation
what we'll see is that the two
frameworks we were discussing that gave
the same answer when we were trying to
predict what happened when we measure a
actually give different answers when we
try to measure b and
only one of these is consistent with
quantum mechanics
let's start with the superposition state
and let's use again the same
superposition of u1 and u2
what's the probability of getting a
particular mu m when we measure b
in state psi using the rules of quantum
mechanics this probability is given by
the absolute value squared of this
bracket we can expand psi in terms of u1
and u2
and multiply through to get this the
absolute value squared is given by the
product of the complex conjugate of the
argument
multiplied by the argument itself
carrying out the multiplication we can
start with this term times this term
which gives this
then this term times this term
which gives this
and then the cross terms that can be
combined to this
now feel free to pause here for a moment
to convince yourself of this
multiplication step
when i've used the fact that the sum of
a number plus its complex conjugate
gives twice
the real part but moving on there is the
probability of getting mu
m when we measure b in the superposition
state psi
now what happens in the case of a
statistical mixture of states
in this case we have state u1 with
probability
c1 squared and state u2 with probability
c2 squared if we have u1
then the probability of getting mu m is
simply this
and if we have u2 the probability of
getting mu m is this
putting this together the total
probability of getting mu m
is the probability of having u1 in the
first place
times the probability of getting mu m in
state u1
plus the probability of having u2 times
the probability of getting mu m in
state u2 okay so now we come to the key
point of this slide
if we compare the probability up here
for the superposition state
with the probability down here for a
statistical mixture of states
we see that the predictions are
different for a measurement of b
in the case of a superposition state we
have this extra term here
that is not present in the case of a
mixture of states
this term is called the interference
term and is essential
the predictions of quantum mechanics
only agree with experiment
if this term is included even one of the
most basic quantum mechanical
experiments
the double slit experiment cannot be
understood
unless we include this interference term
this shows that the correct framework to
describe quantum mechanics
is the one corresponding to
superposition states
although statistical mixtures may
occasionally lead to the same
predictions as quantum mechanics
in general they'll fail
let's go back for a moment to the
comparison between our two frameworks
we've just seen that although for a
measurement of a these two frameworks
predict the same probabilities down here
only superpositions of state are
consistent with quantum mechanics when
we try to measure a second physical
property b
however a statistical mixture of states
can still be important
just like we do in classical mechanics
we may encounter situations in quantum
mechanics
in which we don't have enough
information about our system
in these cases we do need to consider
statistical mixture of states
these statistical mixtures come with
their own probabilistic step
here but it has nothing to do with the
posture of quantum mechanics it simply
reflects the fact that we don't have
enough information about our system
at the state selection step when we have
a quantum mechanical system
for which we only have partial
information then what we need to do is
to consider both
this probabilistic step which derives
from the lack of information
and this probabilistic step would derive
it from the positive of quantum
mechanics
to finish i simply want to describe some
commonly used nomenclature for what
we've been discussing
if we know everything there is to know
about our quantum system
then probability is a purely quantum
effect that arises when we perform
measurements
when this happens we say that we have
pure states
as an example the state psi that we've
been discussing today
is a pure state if instead we only have
partial information about our system
then probability enters in two places
first
we have the quantum mechanical
probability associated with measurements
just like we do for pure states but
second
the lack of knowledge about our system
means that we must also use probability
to describe which state we're actually
dealing with in the first place
this has nothing to do with quantum
mechanics and is something that also
happens in the classical world
when this happens we say we have mixed
states
an example that you'll often encounter
when we only have incomplete information
about our system
arises when we have a macroscopic system
with a number of particles of the order
of avogadro's number
with so many particles it is impossible
to fully characterize the system
be it classically or quantum
mechanically what we do instead
is to use probability in the context of
statistical mechanics
for example a system at thermodynamic
equilibrium at temperature t
has a probability of being in a state of
energy e proportional
to e to the minus e over kbt where kb is
boltzmann's constant
so a mixed state in quantum mechanics is
a state for which we only have partial
information in this sense
for example the state could be psi 1
with probability p1
psi 2 with probability p2 and so on
for this to make sense the sum over the
different probabilities must add to 1
because the system is in some state
note that each of these states psi 1 psi
2 and so on are pure states
so each has the quantum mechanical
probability associated with it
when we perform a measurement however we
don't know in which of this pure state
our system is
this is where the p probabilities come
in they tell us how likely each pure
state is
the p probabilities are independent of
quantum mechanics they simply encode our
lack of knowledge
about the state of the system
pure states are probably what you're
most familiar with from studying quantum
mechanics even if you hadn't called them
by this name
for example in our series on the
postulate of quantum mechanics
all we've been using are pure states but
mixed states also play an important role
for example to describe macroscopic
systems with many particles for which an
exact description is impossible an
area where mixed states are essential is
in quantum statistical mechanics
and a very good starting point for you
to start learning about that is to check
our videos on the density operator
and as always if you like the video
please subscribe